Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Luke Kemp. He's a
research affiliate at the University of Cambridge, and today
we're talking about his book Goliath's Curse The History
and Future of Societal Collapse. So Dr. Kemp, welcome
to the show. It's a big pleasure to
everyone. I got it. Thank you for having me.
So tell us first, what do you mean by
the term Goliath in your book and also what
characterizes a state because we are always constantly using
this term state state, but what does it really
mean?
Let's start with Goliath. Goliath is essentially my replacement
term for civilization. When you go to write a
book on collapse, the obvious question is what is
collapsing? Most people respond to civilization, yet I found
when I tried to look for good definitions of
civilization, they were hard to come by. There was
just a real lack of a consistent idea of
what characterizes it as civilization. When I looked at
it empirically instead, when I actually tried to look
at what is common across all these early civilizations.
You do find one thing, which is they are
all a movement away from egalitarianism towards a dominance
hierarchy, in which a few people impose rules using
violence and others and extract resources from them. The
second problem with the civilization is that it's always
been the term propaganda. It comes from the Latin
root civilitas, which means to live in cities, but
it has connotations of virtue, moderation, wisdom, restraint. When
you look at these first civilizations, if you will,
they're always marked by things like mass human sacrifice,
slavery, patriarchy. Doesn't seem particularly civilized to me. Instead
I thought Goliath, with its biblical connotations of, Intimidating
size, violence, and surprising fragility was a much better
description of what we're actually seeing happen here. The
state is slightly different. A state, probably know the
typical definition from Weber of a monopoly on violence,
that's not quite correct. The idea that it's a
legitimate monopoly on violence wouldn't apply to most early
states who very rarely had a monopoly on violence,
and who decides what what's legitimate, right? Mhm. In
this case, what most scholars agree on as a
state is essentially a set of centralized institutions that
impose rules on a given population in a confined
territory. There's overlap, as you see between state and
Goliath, but they are kind of different. A state
is just a political apparatus. Well, the Roman and
Goliath, for instance, wouldn't just be the empire, it's
also the difference between slave and master, rich and
poor, man and woman, all the other accompanying dominant
hierarchies that hold the society together. So Goliath is
a much larger fixture, but the state is usually
the beating heart of the Goliath.
Uh, I just wanted to ask you, uh, when
you mentioned civilization, is civilization, I mean, whatever it
means, of course, because as you mentioned, there is
a diffused term and even I remember back in
2024 interviewing Doctor Amanda Padeni, she's, uh, an expert
on ancient Mesopotamian because it is referred to usually
as the cradle of civilization. We discussed that term
and she also told me, she's a historian in.
This case, and she also told me that it
doesn't have a um an agreed upon definition, so
it's a bit of a diffused term for historians,
political scientists, and other people like that, but uh
you said at a certain point or associated civilization
with the rise of inequality. I mean, is it
necessarily the case that all um. Let's call them
that way, pre-civilized societies, um, traditional societies like, for
example, hunter-gatherers, horticulturalists, and others, are they all necessarily
egalitarian because back in 2023, for example, I interviewed
Dr. Manvier Singh, who's an anthropologist, and he wrote.
A very interesting paper together with Luke Loaki about
going beyond the egalitarian nomadic model of hunter gatherers.
So I mean apparently there are or there were
even some, not many of course, but some tribes.
Uh, TRADITIONAL societies who are not, um, equal, I,
I mean, there's some inequality in them,
right? Absolutely, and I cover both Mandar and Luke's
work in the book as well. In short, there
are certainly signs of having more hierarchical and unequal
different groups of hunter-gatherers, as well as pastoralists. In
general, they're united by certain kinds of resources, resources
that only become available after the Paleolithics. This is
where I disagree with Mountvier and Luke, they think
these existed all the way during the ice ages,
and there's simply not much evidence of that. And
instead, when you actually see these groups across the
world in places like the Pacific Northwest of both
Canada and the United States, where you have these
hierarchical hunter-gatherers who live in more sedimentary conditions, they
usually rely upon aquatic resources, things like smoked fish.
And as we'll see later in the discussion, this
is usually the key to having any kind of
Goliath, and interestingly, I think when people look at
these more unequal, hierarchical hunter-gatherers, they usually think, They
look in some way more civilized, right? They have
a hierarchy, they often have rulers, they have things
like slavery, they have large monuments, they have sometimes
even human sacrifice, and they often live in at
least temporary villages. So it's simply, it's definitely not
the case that egalitarian, If you're a hunter-gatherer, you
have to be egalitarian, but it is certainly the
case that prior to the rise of the very
first Goliaths, the predominant mode of living was being
a nomadic egalitarian hunter-gatherer. Worth noting with caveats of
people begin to settle down more, you have this
kind of fluid movement between sedentary and nomadic, but
despite those caveats, it is a pretty clear movement
from egalitarianism towards domination.
Yes, I'm going to ask you a little bit
more about prehistoric societies in a bit, but I
would like to ask you now about what do
you mean by collapse exactly? I mean, because I
would imagine that regular people, when they hear or
read the term collapse, they would imagine that it's
just the entire society going under. I mean, everyone
who lives there just disappearing out of existence or
all single social institution that operated there just getting
completely destroyed, collapsing, but is it really? Like that,
or is it, or perhaps should we understand it
more as a form of transformation, and there are
certain things that are maintained and perhaps it's good
even for some people but not so much for
others.
To start with, collapse is definitely not an ancient
apocalypse, and this has always been one of the
biggest misunderstandings around collapse, is people think everyone dies,
everything falls apart. And then you have these weird
discussions and debates amongst archaeologists, with some saying, well,
look, the Maya still carry forward their culture, their
cuisine practices, their language is still several million speakers
of Mayan today. But it's quite clear that the
cities do fall apart, at least most of them,
many still do persevere. And it's quite clear the
overarching kind of political fabric in many ways it
starts to also fall apart. I also don't think
it's just simply a transformation. Transformation is way too
broad a term for what's happening here. One could
very easily argue that Rome was transforming in some
way every single day, and if you start to
lump in collapses with globalization, world wars, etc. YOU
start to end up with a term which is
essentially useless, so I don't think it's simply a
transformation either. The way I think of collapse is
the contraction and fragmentation of power networks. When a
state falls apart, we call it a state failure
or a state collapse. When the economy does a,
does a dives down, we tend to talk about
bit of an economic collapse or a recession. When
there's a large drop in population, we call it
a population bust or a population collapse. When multiple
different power structures begin to deteriorate together, we call
that a societal collapse. And it's worth noting here
that it can have bad outcomes, people can die,
but overall it's a process with winners and losers,
costs and benefits. It's no apocalypse.
Um, AND I mean, is there that certain, uh,
types of people tend to end up as losers
and others, others as winners, are there patterns to
that or not?
There is. Importantly, in general, roughly the average person
often ends up being better off. It varies across
case studies and there's very few hard, fast laws
across history. But in general, this tended to be
a process that was much worse for those who
held power for the elites, and much better for
the average person. Again, there's variation, there are cases
where elites simply migrate from one regime to another
quite seamlessly, for instance, during the Ottoman conquest of
the Byzantine, essentially most of the Byzantine elites just
end up adopting Arabic names thereafter. So, There's certainly
variation, but the kind of general rule is if
you're an elite, you're gonna have a bad time.
If you're an average person, it actually won't be
too bad.
Mhm. Um, AND I mean, uh, I know that
you, you've worked on data sets like the mortality
of states or morals data set. Uh, WHAT have
you learned from, uh, those kinds of data sets?
I mean, there's also CHT out there, and I've
interviewed both Daniel. Hoyer and Dr. Peter Turchin, and
we talked about that, but uh what have you
learned as researchers from those kinds of data sets?
I mean, are there commonalities in terms of the
factors that lead to collapse societal collapse?
Indeed, both Dan and Peter are good friends of
mine, fantastic work, and I draw heavily upon the
Sacha database throughout the book. In order to do
any kind of large scale historical analysis, you need
this kind of databases. One thing we did previously
back in 2023 was we had an article published
in PNAS which looks at both Moros, which is
this database of over 300 states, in this case
I think it's 324 to be precise, over the
period 2000 BC through to 1800. And we compared
that to data in SAA as well, to look
at, do states age? Do states become more likely
to collapse or terminate over time. And what we
found was that over the first two centuries in
general's pattern, states become more likely to terminate, and
then they reach a very high level of risk
and that becomes stable thereafter. So there's some evidence
that there is a kind of aging effect at
the very least early on for states. And one
thing you find that's common both across, Seshat, but
also across other large historical works such as The
Great Leveler by Walter Scheidel, is that states also
tend to grow more unequal, and of course the
work of Seshat also points towards this being a
key factor in crisis, that as you get greater
inequality, you tend to have things like more intra-elite
competition. And that is part of the story, but
the bigger picture I've had to put forward in
Goliath's curse is that inequality has numerous other effects,
which leads to this pattern of states appearing, seemingly
growing more fragile over time.
Yeah, but inequality definitely seems to be, and of
course Daniel Hoyer and Peter Turchin also put a
lot of focus on that, seems to be a
very common factor, right? And I mean looking at
how inequality tends to evolve across. Across time in
the and across different Goliaths, do you think that
it is just inevitable that inequality grows over time
until it goes beyond a threshold where society just
becomes too unstable?
Inevitable, no. As a general pattern, yes. So I'm
drawing upon the work of Walter Scheidel, a historian
at Stanford, in his book The Great Leveler, where
he points out that once you have a Goliath,
once you have a state, you tend to have
wealth inequality rising inexorably, until you have one of
four great levelers. Mass mobilization warfare like the World
Wars, a pandemic such as the Black Death. A
bloody revolution, such as the Bolshevik revolution or societal
collapse, those level the playing field. But there are
some exceptions in some cases where you have peaceful
leveling occur. For instance, in the case of ancient
Athens, you seem to have a small scale revolution,
not a very large scale bloody one, that leads
to a change towards genuine deep democracy. This form
of democracy which involved both assemblies, the ecclesia, but
also random selection of citizens to serve what was
called the boulet. And granted, this was confined to
just 15% of the population, landholding males. Yet it
does seem to result in both a stagnation and
even a decline in wealth inequality within Athens, and
also a surprisingly high median wage for the average
person in Athens. Mhm. So there are these exceptions
where wealth inequality can be reversed. It's not very
common, but nonetheless it's not inevitable. Unfortunately, the general
pattern across history is the one you've mentioned of
wealth inequality tends to increase over time, that makes
the state more fragile, until it's essentially a hollow,
hollow husk that falls apart due to other shocks,
things like warfare, invaders, disease, climatic change.
Mhm. Yeah, uh, let's put a pin on that
and we'll come back to that toward the end
of our conversation to talk a little bit about,
uh, solutions to inequality and other kinds of issues
that we have to deal with, particularly in modern
states. Uh, SO, uh, let, let's talk a little
bit about certain aspects of human, human nature that
you explore in your book. So, uh, one of
the topics you explore there has to do with.
Violence in prehistoric societies because they're sort of this
obedient view of human nature, right, that we before
civilization our lives were short, brutish, extremely violent, and
all of that. But I mean if I understand
it correctly, and please correct me if I'm wrong,
this is also a view that has been endorsed
by people like Stephen. Pinker in the better angels
of our nature and enlightenment now, but anthropologists like
Brian Ferguson, Douglas Fry, but particularly Brian Ferguson because
he really broke down the different sources of evidence
that Pinker used in his book. I mean, there's,
there seems to be very, very little evidence or
evidence of not, not good enough quality. To really
support the idea that prehistoric societies were incredibly more
violent than our modern industrialized societies are, right?
Precisely. So there's been a very common narrative that
humans are innately violent and bloodthirsty, and often it's
said that during the Paleolithic, during the ice ages,
before we get the Holocene, this warmer period of
climatic stability, and you start to see things like
Agrarianism. We had lethal violence rates of roughly 15
to 25%. In other words, for every 100 people,
roughly 15 to 25% of them would die at
the hands of another human being. Yeah, Steven Pinker,
of course, is one of the most vociferous proponents
of this idea, and he puts forward historically more
15%. And in general, you have three different forms
of evidence you can rely upon for this claim.
One is anthropological, looking at existing hunter-gatherers. The second
is archaeological, looking at skeletons from the record, particularly
from the Paleolithic, and the third is genetic. When
we look at anthropological, it's really unclear how much
we can take from that, because there's such a
huge variation here. We go all the way from
0% to 55%, so there's 0% for I think
the Bakari to 0%, sorry, to 55% for the
Aceh. The problem is that most of these cases
also involve colonizers, warfare of farmers, etc. THINGS like
alcohol as well. They're really not a good insight
to what happens in the deep past. For instance,
almost all the war deaths attributed in the Ace
are actually from colonizers, they're from people who wouldn't
have existed during the Paleolithic.
Uh, ALSO, I, I'm sorry for interrupting, but I
think that even there are many, many anthropologists out
there and perhaps a very good name to refer
to here is Robert Kelly and his book The
Lifeways of Hunter-gatherers, that they argue that we have
to be extremely careful when studying modern day hunter-gatherer
societies. Societies and making conclusions about how well they
represent prehistoric hunter gatherer societies because particularly the ecological
conditions they live in tend to be very specific
to the kind of geography that they inhabit and
also the kind. Of, uh, modern day conditions they
find themselves in.
Exactly, no archaeologist and anthropologist would say that nomadic
egalitarian hunter-gatherers or any hunter-gatherers today are completely archaic
emblems of what happened during the Paleolithic. That being
said, there are cases we made that certain groups
like the Hatza in Tanzania or the Khoisan people
in Kadahari Desert are probably closer. Windows into what
the Paleolithic was like, for a few reasons. One
is we know they had continued genetic presence in
that area, all the way back to the Paleolithic,
with no large scale changes in material culture that
are visible, and the second one being that when
you look at the archaeology of the Paleolithic, it
looks very similar to how we see people live
in these areas today. Mhm. Putting that aside, so
anthropology is something we can't heavily rely upon here.
The archaeological evidence paints a very clear picture. And
as you mentioned, Steven Pinker here is worth noting
has been torn apart by Brian Ferguson. His large
scale database he uses has multiple duplicates, and only
one site, just one comes from the Paleolithic. Instead,
there's been a much better study done by two
archaeologists from the Field Museum in Chicago, where they
looked across over 4000 skeletons and 3000 sites, and
found essentially no clear, Equivocal evidence of violence, except
for one which is very well-known, what's called Jabelsa
Harbor, where roughly, I think it was roughly 50
skeletons were found with signs of violence and trauma
on them. Notably this occurred right at the end
of the Paleolithic, essentially during the transition towards the
Holocene, in an area that was undergoing immense environmental
change, so not exactly emblematic of the wider Paleolithic.
And When we look at genetic evidence, it also
points out a picture of us being relatively peaceful,
that the very maximum ceiling from the genetic evidence
was roughly 2% lethal violence rate. And it's worthwhile
even taking that with a grain of salt, this
is a study where essentially you look at other
species, you get an estimate of how often they
kill within their own groups, and then you're more
likely to extrapolate that to humans based upon which
one is most closely genetically related to humans, for
instance, chimps are obviously much closer to us than
fruit flies. But all the evidence we have points,
paints a pretty clear picture that humans simply aren't
super violent, and one of the most compelling points
I find is that when you look across the
archae archaeological record, even when you start to get
signs of violence, you don't have signs of large
scale warfare. Instead, warfare emerges as you get people
becoming more sedentary, but also getting access to certain
resources. What I call lootable resources, resources that are
easily seen, stolen and stored, things like grain. And
that makes sense as well. There wasn't much point
in going to war and risking your life with
no material benefit, which for nomadic egalitarians, hunter-gatherers who
carry no surplus on them, there just really wasn't
a strong reason to go to war.
Yes, to put it in very simple terms, I
mean really for people to understand in a very
straightforward manner what we're talking about here, it seems
to me, and please correct me if I'm wrong,
that warfare and conflict between different human societies really
scales up when people are able to accumulate resources,
right, that can that other people. And fight over.
Yeah, I think it's in particular the accumulation of
certain types of resources, resources that can be easily
stored and can be easily transported, what I call
lootable resources. Notably, the very first example of warfare
we have is in northern Mesopotamia, with a group
called the Halafians trying to monopolize the trade on
obsidian. Obsidian is a valuable resource which can be
stockpiled and can also be transported over vast distances.
And this is also the key to why Goliath
got created. You don't see goliaths just popping up
when you have a surplus necessarily. There are numerous
hunter-gatherer groups who have surpluses, but don't seem to
create goliaths. And similarly there's numerous areas across the
world which have agriculture, they have surpluses, but again,
don't create Goliath, Papua New Guinea being a great
example. It had agriculture at the same time as
Egypt. The key difference here is Papua New Guinea
has yams, taro, and banana. Banana you can store
for roughly 1 month, yam and tara roughly 6
months, yaminara you grow underground and you can keep
it underground even when it's ready to be harvested.
Wheat, rice, barley, corn, the staple crops that we
used in the very first go lives, the very
first civilisations, they all can be stored for decades
on end. They're very easily seen, and hence they're
very easily looted, what I call lootable resources, easily
seen, stolen and stored.
Uh, WHEN it comes to violence, uh, what do
you make of the work by people like Dr.
Richard Wrangham, who wrote the very fascinating book The
Goodness Paradox? I've interviewed, I interviewed him back in
2019. Where through his own research, research of his
collaborators and other people, he suggests that actually when
it comes to what he, what he, what he
calls in the book self- domestication, I mean we
as humans self domesticating violence. PLAYED an important role
in traditional societies and throughout our evolution in the,
in this very specific way of turning against anti-social
individuals that tried to rise to power in those
kinds of societies and. Maybe we can even talk
about other kinds of societies where anti-social individuals rise
to power. I mean, what do you make of
his claims and potentially the role that that specific
kind of violence played in our evolution?
We certainly do still see some violence, it's usually
interpersonal violence, other acts of passion, for instance, in
hunter-gatherer groups, or what are called counter dominant strategies.
This is mainly the work of Christopher Bow in
particular, where he essentially documented that in nomadic egalitarian
groups, when one individual tried to dominate the rest
of the group, they were usually handled in 3
different ways. One was ridicule, another was ostracism, being
kicked out of the group, and the third was
in-group executions. And there is certainly evidence of this,
and one really powerful, strange bit of evidence actually
is that when you look at humans, it's quite
clear you get a reproductive advantage, particularly for men
with higher status. Men with higher status tend to
have a larger number of children, and those children
more likely to live dadhood. There's a reproductive evolutionary
story here. And that's one of the reasons why
you try and dominate a group, right, is you
want status, you want that reproductive advantage deep down
inside. And yet we have far less of an
advantage compared to chimpanzees and other primates. They're roughly
4 times the reproductive benefit of status compared to
humans, which suggests an evolutionary story of humans relative
to our to our primate, primate ancestors, we found
a way to select against those who were seeking
status through dominance. Hence these counter dominant skills. So
it's quite clear that in many ways we weren't
just egalitarian because we didn't have a surplus, we
didn't have little resources, it was also a social
choice.
Yes, mhm. Uh, SO in terms of our history,
we tend to have this very linear view of
history in the sense that we tend to think
that we just, uh, up to a certain point
were hunter gatherers, foragers, and then we moved into
agricultural societies, and now we have industrialized societies and
so on. Is that really how we should think
about or look? Back at history, I mean, it
was there really a linear progression where let's say
10 to 13,000 years ago around the advent of
the Holocene, uh, people who were living in hunter
gatherer societies just progressively moved into agricultural societies and
there was never any turn back for them. Uh,
I mean, is that really the case?
Certainly not in the short-term. When we look at
the transition from intensified agriculture towards adopting states, that
on average took roughly 3000 years, in some cases
far longer. This was a, a very staccato, slow,
messy process over the space of centuries, often millennia.
Likewise we were living in more sedentary conditions, often
hunter-gatherers started living in more sedentary conditions, sometimes they
became more mobile, a great example here being the
early groups during the initial um transition to the,
into the Holocene in Mesopotamia, they start to to
settle down and eventually when you have the Juanga
driest period, essentially a period of cooling, they go
back to being nomadic egalitarians. There's also numerous cases
where people seem to pick up farming and then
they lose it. A great example here being Neolithic
Europe, where essentially farmers spread all the way from
modern day Turkey and Anatolia, up across Europe all
the way to the British Isles, and they go
through these boom bust cycles where you see them
grow in numbers, but they also grow in inequality.
And then you start to see the first signs
of warfare, they collapse dramatically in population, but they
also give up most of their farming. They start
to move toward things like eating chestnuts, for instance,
in the British Isles. And for a long period
of time thereafter, they rely more upon hunting and
gathering and pastoralism rather than farming. So these were
not clear, unavoidable points of no return. People often
shifted between different kinds of subsistence patterns. All that
being said, there is also a really clear pattern
across history, that once you get a Goliath, once
you get an empire, they tend to always come
back, and they eventually grow bigger and bigger. Whether
you look at Europe, China, the Near East, South
America, Mesoamerica, in every single case, once you get
a Goliath, even if it collapses, it eventually comes
back, and they grow bigger over time until eventually
it cover the entire territory. The only exception we
have here is North America, where you have a
whole set of early Goliaths, places like Cahokia, and
early city in modern day Saint Louis, and roughly
10,000 to 15,000 people where they practiced large scale
human sacrifice. All the Pabloan communities, the very first
farmers of the US Southwest who built these large
sandstone houses and group in, in small villages. And
once they fall apart, roughly 1000 years ago, they
don't seem to come back. But it's an open
question because Europeans arrived roughly 2 centuries there, a
couple of centuries thereafter. And if Europeans don't arrive,
would you eventually see another Goliath occur and essentially
spread over North America? Most likely in the long
run, yes.
Uh, BUT are there historic examples of people abandoning
a Goliath?
There are, there are numerous ones I mentioned in
the book, both Jenna Jenna, for instance, in East
Africa, Tiwaku in South America, the very earliest state,
someone saved South America, San Lorenzo Ernesto America, there's
at least a dozen or more examples I cover
in the book of these, we can think of
them as the B to Goliaths, they're experiments of
doing dominance in the hierarchy, but they fail in
some kind of way. Often it is, A situation
in which you start to build a city, you
start to have most of the trimmings of civilization,
but without having a big dominance hierarchy, and then
elites, and rulers start to pop up, like in
the case of Tiwaku for instance, and then it
becomes unstable thereafter. And to me, what these often
look like are kind of scaled up versions of
counter dominance strategies. You either see sometimes revolt, where
you actually see elites preferentially killed, as well as
elite infrastructure destroyed. Or sometimes you see in the
case of Cochia for instance, people just seemingly walk
away. The collapse was basically just migration out of
the city until it had only a few small
elite families and it crumbled apart from there. And
both of those in some ways look like ostracism
and in-group executions of would-be dominators. In some strange
way, they are scaled up counter dominant strategies.
Mhm. Uh, SO let me just ask you a
question about early agricultural societies because sometimes people discuss
this. Uh, IN your understanding, what were the positive
and negative aspects? Of early agricultural societies because I've
talked with anthropologists about this and there seems to
be the case that at least in the early
stages of uh agricultural societies, um, people had uh
uh uh some disadvantages compared to people who lived
in hunter-gatherer societies, correct?
Yeah, so there's been a wronggoing idea that the
movement towards agrarian societies, towards agriculture, was a physiological
nightmare. This was a wrecking ball to human health,
and you do see this in some ways, for
instance, the, Evidence of dental caries and weaker bones,
bone lesions both increase, you also have a drop
in human height. Across most areas, you have a
drop of a few inches, and human height is
a good overall biophysical indicator of your health. People
tend to be taller when they have access to
more calories, more protein, more varied diets, and less
exposure to starvation or disease. And you see, even
when you look at modern day thematic egalitarian hunter-gatherers
versus business farmers, they tend to be taller and
healthier in a whole bunch of ways. There's actually
some interesting evidence to go in the book that
even compared to industrial counterparts, there seem to be
some strange phenomena like very low incidence of cardiovascular
disease and actually slower atrophy of the brain. But
putting that aside, it seems like agriculture was something
that was not good for our health at all.
But there are some benefits to that culture. One
is that you can support a larger density of
population in a given area. And this seems to
be quite important later on once you start to
get much denser, bigger groups. And the second is
that, it's something you can rely upon even when,
say for instance, animals start to die off, and
this is one leading theory for why you get
agriculture intensification in certain areas like Mesopotamia, is you
also start to see the die-off of very large,
Animals such as aurochs for instance, and instead people
start to rely more upon agriculture, and then all
it takes is a couple of bad seasons, people
have to rely more upon agriculture and they get
stuck in this trap where the population is so
large, they can't be sustained by hunting and gathering,
they have to rely at least in part on
agriculture. And I think there's, and the second wrinkle
to this is agriculture is also potentially more useful
for status competition. This is. Largely based upon a
big body of work on feasting, which essentially finds
that feasting is often practiced in a number of
different societies as a way of one individual or
group gaining more status, and often feasting items were
items used and produced in agriculture, both exotic ones
like avocados and peppers, but also even basic ones
such as wheat.
Um, LET me ask you this, uh, I mean,
it's not that I take, uh, someone like Yuval
Noah Harari, very seriously. I mean, I don't, I
don't, particularly when it comes to particularly when it
comes to anthropology, not at all, but, um, I,
I want to address particular claims that he and
other people make, like, for example, when they say
that. It was, um, I'm paraphrasing here, but it
was a mistake for people to make the move
to agricultural societies, and they point to things like
rising inequality, warfare, the origins of patriarchy, slavery, hierarchical
societies. I mean, all of those kinds of things.
Do you think that we can really say scientifically?
THAT it that moving to agricultural societies or establishing
agricultural societies was a mistake that we are worse
off uh through uh now that we've gone through
that process than we would have been if we
just kept living in hunter gatherer societies. I mean,
is that uh some question that we can answer
scientifically?
Scientifically we can detail what happened, we can describe
the pros and cons of the transition towards agriculture
and how these changed over time. For the 1st
5000 years, it seems to have been a real
wrecking ball to human health, but also even just
to in general our way of life. Once you
start to get both the industrial revolution, but also
importantly in the industrial revolution, plus progressive movements like
unionists, suffragettes, etc. Then you start to see a
change, you start to see a rise in literacy,
declines in infant maternal mortality, increases in longevity, life
expectancy, etc. ALL the kind of good things that
are usually shown in our world in data, life
in short, gets better. But was it worthwhile? Was
this a mistake? That's something of a, of a
value judgment, and it really depends upon what you
value in many ways. Some people could of course
look back on those thousands of years of warfare,
slavery, patriarchy, suffering and say, well, it was tough,
but now we managed to get to the moon.
We know what stars are, and all the achievements
in the modern world, they make that worthwhile. Others
would look at genocides today, they'd look at the
genocides of the past. And they look at the,
the fact, and this is the most surprising fact
I found in the book, that when you look
at nomadic egalitarian hunter-gatherers today using happiness surveys, they
seem to be on average happier than their counterparts
in Spain and the US and other industrialized countries.
You could look at that kind of evidence and
say, well no, this was not worthwhile, this was
a tragic mistake. It all depends upon what you
value. I think when it comes to health, at
least for the 1st 5000 years, it's pretty clear
cut that this was a mistake.
Mhm. No, it's very interesting because back in 2021,
if I remember correctly, I interviewed Doctor Kim Hill.
I mean, one of the leading anthropologists who've studied
the wider number of uh traditional societies, and I,
I asked him more or less the same question.
I asked him, look, is, uh, do you think
it's possible for us to really uh tell scientifically
whether It's better to live in a modern industrialized
society or in a traditional hunter-gatherer society, and he
told me the same. He said, Look, it's for
me it's more of a value judgment. I can
tell you about negative things that I saw, uh,
living in, uh, living together with hunter-gatherers and negative
things that we have in modern industrialized. Society and
they gave the example of um hunter gatherer societies
where we lived that at night children would be
crying because there would be no food and that's
something that we, I mean, virtually do not see.
I mean, we, we can debate that, but we
virtually do not see in modern industrialized societies and,
but, and the example of a negative thing that
he gave. IN modern industrialized societies has to do
with loneliness, for example. I mean, there's apparently an
increasing number of people who suffer from loneliness, and
that's just not something that you really see in
hunter gatherer societies, and those are just two examples.
So yeah, there's also just a very simple point
of it, it depends upon who you are. There's
a wonderful book, I think it's called Prehistoric Myths
in Modern Political Philosophy, which examines how much of
our philosophy we rely upon today. It involves a
judgment of having civilization, having cities, having a state,
having a Goliath, is worthwhile if it makes both
the average person or at the very least, the
very worst off person better, if they have a
better life overall. And the thing they point out
is, it's hard to determine this on average because
as you mentioned, it depends upon a whole bunch
of things you're measuring. But when it comes to
the very worst off, they actually make a pretty
compelling case that, The very worst off in industrialized
societies are probably much worse off than people in
hunter-gatherer groups, at least the people in hunter-gatherer groups,
there's a level of certain equality, but importantly, they
still have social connections usually. While you can have
people who are incredibly destitute, marginalized, and often on
terrible, terrible drugs in industrialized societies, so, the very
depth of human suffering can reach, that can also
vary depending upon your type of society. So, I
think it's a tricky question, but there's still a
really important overarching, Piece here, which is this idea
that collapse is often a dark age after an
ascension into a golden age of an empire, is
clearly incorrect, um, instead often you do find a
situation where empires meant people were shorter and less
healthy. For instance, after the collapse of Rome, people
seem to grow taller and healthier, they have those
taller skeletons but also less dental cavities and bone
lesions and, The obvious of talk there is so
many people die, that the survivors have many leftover
resources and hence grow healthier. That doesn't seem to
be the case. First of all, we have very
unclear estimates of how many people actually died in
different areas, but secondly and more importantly, people outside
the empire were taller and healthier than those inside
the empire. Hence the old trope of the muscle-bound
genetic barbarian. So it's a much more complicated picture
of history, one where sometimes collapse could in certain
cases be good for the average person.
Mhm. So, uh, let me ask you now, uh,
about, uh, certain, uh, specific, uh, states because I,
I'm very interesting to hear, uh, very interested to
hear your thoughts about them. So, um, What is
the deal with China, for example, because it seems
throughout history that it has gone through its stages
where there was apparent collapse and it and then
it came back again. I mean, of course there
were periods where China, or what we now call
China, it was several different states and There were
periods of unification and in more recent history, of
course it was torn apart by the English and
the Opium Wars and all of that which eventually
led arguably to the communist revolution and now we
have a state that I'm mean, I'm not even
sure if there's a definite answer as to whether
it is a form of socialism or state capitalism.
I mean people debate that a lot. I don't
know if you have a particular opinion on that,
but what do you make of China? Has it
ever really gone through real collapse and then came
back, or what's the deal with it?
I think it has. If you had, for instance,
the Warring States period or The spring and autumn
period in Europe, they would have called that a
collapse rather than what they're called in China, which
is they give it a very particular chronological imperialization
name. I think there's a couple of reasons, one
of those is just simple historical convention, but another
is you do see a continuity throughout China, even
during these periods of disunity, during these periods of
fragmentation, and part of this is, That China has
a consistent language throughout most of these periods and
a consistent form of writing, particularly after the Qin
dynasty, who tried to essentially standardize both weights, measurements,
but also things like writing a script and language.
But also bureaucracy, the bureaucracy often, more or less
seamlessly moves between different regimes, and we can talk
about the fall of different dynasties, but the bureaucracy
and the kind of underlying culture, many of the
institutions still persist and continue across different dynasties. So
there are certain, Collapses throughout Chinese history, but I
think you do find a strange level of continuity,
which you often don't find in other areas, and
it's notable in general that China, once you get
large standing empire over China, it doesn't tend to
fall apart. Well when you look at say for
instance, Europe, you only have one period where there's
an empire which essentially encompasses all of Europe for
a prolonged period of time, which is Rome, Rome
is exceptional. Thereafter, it doesn't really happen again. France
gets closed, but it holds the entirety of Europe
for less than a decade before it falls apart.
China has been almost having large scale unified empire,
despite these periods of fragmentation, which there were still
many. Why is that, um, part of it seems
to be cultural, that China did have a much
bigger focus upon building things like bureaucracy, a common
script, the efforts of the Chin to really standardize
things seems to be crucial here. And part of
it seems to be geographic as well, it was
just simply, there were less large scale mountain ranges
and other areas to essentially break up imperial conquest,
which led to a larger unified imperial cultural zone.
And also China just also gets a Goliath much
earlier, and you find across history that areas which
developed Goliath's earliest tend to stay autocratic even in
later times, Egypt, China being great examples. Those who
developed states much later where you already have stronger
norms and practices of larger scale democracy, they tend
to have more of a democratic flavor later on,
like in Europe.
OK, so I really have to ask you about
this idea that you explore in your book. I'm
not sure if you were trying to be a
little bit provocative here or not, but tell us
about this idea of states as organized crime. I
mean, what do you mean by that?
So I mentioned that when you try to look
at the origin of Goliaths, one of the key
things here is lootable resources. You get a little
resources in in Egypt, but not in Papua New
Guinea, and that helps to explain why you get
a Goliath in Egypt, but you never get pharaohs
in Papua New Guinea. Lootable resources seem to be
critical, but there's another two factors. One is monopolized
weapons, weapons that can be monopolized by a single
group. So for instance, in both Egypt, China, as
well as Mesopotamia, you don't get Goliaths occurring until
you have the introduction of handheld bronze axes and
swords. Even later on in places like the Kingdom
of Hawaii, that doesn't occur until you have the
introduction of essentially musket-based guns. Frequently we see when
the hunter-gatherer groups get introduced to monopolized weapons, they
start to become more hierarchical, more Goliath-like. And the
third is, in many cases, these early Goliaths were
in areas where people had very few exit options,
where they couldn't easily disperse. For instance, Egypt is
locked between the Red Sea and the Nile. Mesopotamia,
it means the land between two rivers, the Tigris
and the Euphrates, that is in Greek of course.
So it's these three ingredients which I call Goliath
fuel, lootable resources, monopolized weapons, and caged land, which
seem to explain the emergence of Goliaths across history.
And that paints a pretty clear picture of what's
happening. A small number of people are getting access
to weapons which they can use to take the
resources that others depend upon, and the others can't
escape and have to accept the new arrangement. In
almost every case, we'd call that a story of
organized crime, not a story of civilization occurring. And
it's noticeable that when you actually look into definitions
of warlord, organized crime and state, they're actually kind
of similar. They all basically involve taking an unorganized
market and making it more hierarchically organized, using violence.
I think it seems strange to us, and it
seems unnerving and uncomfortable because we're used to states
today providing public services, but we have to remember
that that wasn't true of the states of the
past. Most states of the past were much more
predatory, much more unequal, and frankly much more like
organized crime rackets than they were like Denmark.
You know, I, I'm really curious because, uh, and
now I'm talking about my own personal experience, and
this is of course not a strictly scientific approach.
It also has to do with my personal values,
but I've, I've been pretty much a socialist since
I was 18. I'm now 35, but as I
read more and more and more anthropology, uh, I
mean, little by little, it seems that I'm leaning
more and more toward anarchism. I mean, do, do
you have that same sort of experience or not?
Yes, in short, it's worthwhile already quickly defining what
we mean by when we say anarchism, because most
people, when they hear anarchism for the first time,
they think of someone in a black hoodie, throwing
a Molotov cocktail or a brick through a window.
They think of chaos. And that's largely the outcome
of a very well coordinated, successful propaganda campaign, where
states and elites have essentially sought to discredit the
idea. But anarchism, when you look at the philosophy
from people like Praudun, Bakunin, etc. IT tends to
be essentially trying to find ways to do large
scale cooperation, which does not rely upon violent hierarchy.
To me, that is essentially just taking democracy seriously.
How do we ensure political equality and that we
can essentially coordinate without recourse to violence? When you
actually talk about it that way, most people agree
that's something that's worth pursuing, that is the ideal
political arrangement. And it's quite clear that's also what
we had most of the time as well. For
the 1st 300,000 years or so of human society,
we appear to have live in nomadic egalitarian arrangements
with no clear rules and no persistent levels of
inequality. But we are still capable of quite clearly
of large scale coordination cooperation. I talk about in
the book, for instance, that you have evidence of
shared musical instruments, lithic tools, so stone tools, genes
in culture, sometimes even figurine and cave art all
the way from the east coast to the west
coast of Africa 100,000 years ago. You have similar
big cultural zones all the way from Siberia to
Spain. To me it's pretty clear we can cooperate
and we can coordinate without necessarily having one person
take most of the surplus and threaten everyone else
using weapons. So I've certainly found that my politics
and my values have changed in the course of
writing this book, which took 7 years, and I
always find it funny that I get the critique
as you'd expect of this book is just you,
Reflecting and projecting your values onto the past, I'm
like, no, I, my values were very different prior
to writing this book, this is actually the opposite,
it's learning from history and using that evidence to
change how I think. So yeah, I think like
you, I've actually experienced more of a drift towards
anarchism or one could even just say simply, a
drift towards taking democracy and doing democracy seriously.
So earlier we've already touched a little bit on
this topic, but I want to address it in
a more direct manner. I mean earlier when we
talked about people in traditional societies getting greed in
one form or another of anti-social individuals. Uh, TELL
us about, uh, individuals with dark triad traits. I
mean, narcissism. Berlinism and psychopathy. Why is it that
they seem to be overrepresented in leadership roles, um,
and I mean, do, do you think that, uh,
that there would be mechanisms for us in modern
industrialized and post-industrial societies, uh, to deal with them
in some way?
Hm. The key here appears to be, A, these
people want status much, much more than others. So
the desire for status is universal, everyone wants to
be admired, loved, respected by their peers. But some
people want it far more than others. In general,
men want, want it much more, and also people
in the dark triad who rank high in the
dark triad tend to want it more. It's worthwhile
noting the dark triad, While we often talk about
this as if it's a particular category, everyone has
a certain level of dark triad, everyone has a
certain level of narcissism, Machiavellianism, or psychopathy. What we're
really talking about people who rank highly enough in
these traits that they usually, it's sufficient for a
clinical diagnosis as a psychopath or a narcissist, etc.
The second issue here is not only do they
want status much more, but they're usually more capable
of getting it. They're usually more capable of doing
politics, coalition building, and often resorting to violence. For
instance, people who are psychopaths are much more capable
of doing violence and a much lower in risk
aversion, for instance. So they've have both the means,
and they also have the motivation as well, and
this helps to explain why you do see an
overrepresentation of the dark triad in both parliaments, as
well as in boardrooms. So across the average population,
at least amongst men, roughly 1% of people would
pass the clinical threshold for psychopathy. In boardrooms and
in parliaments, it's roughly 3 to 21%. The numbers
vary quite a lot because it depends upon how
you measure it and the sample size, etc. BUT
there's no dispute whatsoever that it's much, much larger
than the average population. And obviously that's not a
great thing, because while these people want status, they're
usually not the best kinds of leaders, and I
think this actually helps to explain why when you
look at the history textbooks, they're essentially a roll
call of mass murderers. Napoleon, Alexander the Great, Chinghis
Khan, these are not people renowned for their virtue
or even necessarily for being particularly good leaders, they're
usually renowned for their military strategy and their ability
to kill or starve large numbers of people. And
I think it also helps to explain why, When
you look at the average person, they're often not
that bad. When you look at the average state
or kingdom, they're usually quite horrible. The key thing
here is that we're not selecting for the best
of us, instead we're often doing the worst, and
again, status I think is the best explanation for
this, and when you look across history, it's, we
have a clear genetic image that roughly 8000 to
4000 years ago, you start to have a bottleneck
in the Y chromosome, and that appears to be
because a small number of men start to monopolize
reproduction. Essentially, the rulers, emperors of harems, etc. ALL
start to use their status to monopolize reproduction. So,
This is pretty clear that we're not being represented
by the best of us, and this is I
think one of the underlying problems we face in
society today, is how to build up new counter
dominance strategies and build up new political systems that
don't essentially select for the worst of us. And
part of this is quite simple, and I mentioned
before an example of this, which was the use
of sortition in ancient Athens. So rather than having
people compete in elections, they would randomly select people
across the population. And even for ancient ancient Athenians,
ancient Greeks today, they would look at us and
say, you're not a democracy, you're an oligarchy. Because
for them elections were oligarchic. It even comes down
to the actual Latin root of the term elite
and elect all come from the same root of
to be chosen. And it makes sense, in order
to actually compete in an election, you need to
have influence, you need to have money, you have
a lot of spare time to actually go and
compete in an election. Most people don't have those
three things. Instead, sortition randomly selects across the population,
which means you're no longer selecting people who want
power, and you're no longer just selecting people who
are particularly good at violence or particularly good at
politicking, you're just selecting at random. And what we've
strangely see is that when you select at random,
people often make pretty good decisions. We have this
very big body of evidence from what's called deliberate
democracy, where essentially you have these citizens' juries and
assemblies, where you select people at random, you have
them briefed by experts, they deliberate, they exchange information,
they talk, and they come to a policy decision.
In general, these decisions are usually seen as more
trustworthy, legitimate, and also just seem to be better
as well. So I do think there are quite
clear ways to start to avoid the selection processes
we have for people who are high in the
dark triad. And it's also a way of avoiding
the other what I call darker angellar nature. So
in the book I don't just talk about the
dark tribe, the status competition, I also talk about
power corrupting. There's very strong social psychology evidence that
when people are placed in positions of power, they
usually tend to be changed in their personalities, they
become less risk averse, less compassionate and empathetic, more
likely to cheat both in games and in their
spouses, and their brains change, less capable of doing
things like mirroring. And if you only have people
in power for a short period of time, you're
also avoiding that issue of power corrupting as well.
Mhm. Yeah, I mean, by the way, there's also
a very fascinating edited book by Dr. Philip Dwyer,
The Darker Angels of Our Nature, but that's more
of a critique of Steven Pinker's approach to historic
trends in violence, but I also To have an
interview with him is really fascinating. It's really fascinating.
So I, I mean, in the interest of time
because I'm, I'm seeing that we have less than
10 minutes left here, um, I mean talking about
our modern global Goliath, so to speak. Um, DO
you think that if it collapses, and, and by
the way, do you, do you think that there
are signs that it could collapse or could be
collapsing, but if it collapses, its collapse could be
worse than the collapse of any historic Goliath because
now it would be on a global scale.
In the book I put forward the case that
Goliath is no longer regional, instead it is a
global dominance hierarchy or a set of dominance hierarchies.
Every state in the world essentially operates in a
global capitalist economy, even China, I would say. Every
state looks pretty similar actually, they're all incredibly hierarchical
and they have a head of state who reports
to the United Nations. Every single state, particularly great
powers, have similarities in terms of the military as
well. All the great powers have nuclear weapons, they
all have really clear, strong chains of command in
how they operate their navies, their militaries in general,
and all of us seem to have very similar
ways of organizing information. I mean, surveillance capitalist firms,
Google, Amazon, Microsoft, etc. THEY all organize information flows
across the entire world. Always has intelligence agencies that
look pretty similar. The world in many ways is
much more. Similar and homogenized than it's ever been
throughout history, and I think this is large part
because we now live under this single Goliath system.
In the past, what was a real precursor to
collapse, the key indicator, was essentially rising wealth inequality.
As I mentioned earlier, wealth inequality tends to correlate
to a whole bunch of different woes. Things like
we already mentioned before, the works of Peter Turcheon
on intra-elite competition. You have a larger elite class
competing for a small number of high status positions,
and that tends to lead to things like coups,
rebellions. Civil wars, etc. You also tend to get
a, what are what's often called immiseration of the
masses. Basically people start to get poorer because assets
become so expensive, things like land. Today we call
it a cost of living crisis. You also have
other effects, we also see that in general, wealth
inequality tends to correlate with higher levels of corruption,
it also correlates with higher levels of socio-political violence.
And in general, it seems to result in situations
where you have more of an oligarchy. Having a
lot of powerful people with a lot of money
tends to influence the political system, it doesn't just
stay in bank accounts, and that often leads to
worse decision making, because elites, particularly those who are
benefiting immensely in terms of their finances from the
existing status quo, don't have a big interest in
changing things, even if there are oncoming impending disasters.
So all these different effects stack up and hollow
out the state until it falls apart. When we
look across the world, there's very clear signs of
rising wealth inequality. The general trend here is that
we have a, Leveling, what's called the Great Compression
during the World Wars, the world wars have this
great combination of both destroying all the world money,
and also the introduction of different kinds of concessions
and policies from elites to, to the commoners, essentially
because the commoners were armed and more economically valuable
now. So you have the rise of democratic welfare
states. But then wealth inequality starts to rise again
roughly in the 1980s, and with a time lag
of roughly a decade or two, you start to
see all the telltale signs, rising polarization, the rise
of the far right, declining trust in public institutions,
democratic backsliding, etc. Now, I don't think collapse would
be quite the same in the past as it
was, as it collapse won't be quite the same
today as it was in the past. One is
that even if you do have intra-elite competition and
popularmiseration, today we have police forces, intelligence agencies, and
mass surveillance. There's much more effective ways for states
to maintain control than they had in the past.
Even police forces didn't happen in most pre-modern states.
What I'm more worried about is what is often
referred to as existential risk. Things like nuclear weapons,
climate change, advanced AI systems. These also are products
of the global Goliath. When you look at any
of these, they're usually produced by a very small
number of concentrated powerful actors. In the case of
climate change, the fossil fuel industry, in the case
of AI, just 3 big companies, Microsoft, Inward OpenAI,
Google DeepMind, and Annthropic. If you want nuclear weapons,
only really two states have a vast majority, 86%
of the stock stockpiles held by the US and
Russia, and roughly 2 dozen companies are responsible for
maintaining and upgrade the weapons. But in short, Goliath
at a global scale is producing threats that could
destroy essentially the entire world, not just result in
short-term, small, small scale collapse. So while collapse has
a bright past, I think it has a surprisingly
dark future. And that's for a few reasons, as
I mentioned, these threats we face are just a
much larger magnitude. But also weapons today are much
worse than they were in the past. Before, if
you had a, a collapse, yes, you'd have small
groups of men trying to rebuild a state, rebuild
a Goliath, but if you're using things like iron,
swords and axes or muskets, today we have nuclear
weapons. And additionally on top of that is states
today are much better than they were previously. You
know, Denmark actually is good for its citizens, it
does provide important public services and and public goods.
Previous states, pre-modern states, not so much, and last
but not least, most of us can't easily switch
our subsistence base back towards hunting and gathering or
farming, we're entirely reliant upon industrialized, globalized food and
supply chains. And last but not least is if
it's a GL system at a global level, it
means if GLAF collapses, it'll be global, no longer
regional. So for all those reasons, unfortunately collapse going
forward is likely be much worse rather than being
a much more benevolent feature like it was in
the past.
OK, so Doctor Kemp, I'm getting really mindful of
your time. So, uh, do you think that it's
better for us to just wrap up our conversation
here and if you're open to it, we could
have another conversation in the near future to talk
a little bit more about existential threats and modern
states and, and so on, if you're open to
it. Yeah,
I'd be happy to do part 21 day.
OK, OK, thank you so much for, so the
book is again Goliath's Curse, The History and Future
of Societal collapse, and I'm I'm of course leaving
a link to it in the description of the
interview. And Doctor Kemp, apart from your book, where
can people find you and your work on the
internet?
Oh, unfortunately, not many places. I'm not very active
in social media. I do technically have a mastodon
and Blue Sky account. I think it's at Luke
Kemp or Luca Kemp, I think I haven't used
it in quite some time. And I'm on the
sub stack, I've yet to write a post, but
I will, and it's at Elle Kemp, I'm gonna
be calling the sub-stack the final word.
OK, great. So thank you so much for taking
the time to come on the show. I really
loved the book and I was very much looking
forward to this conversation and it's been a real
pleasure to talk with you.
Thanks, Ricardo, I've always been a big fan of
the podcast and I've really enjoyed being on.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegeru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punter DaRosmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortezus Suliliski,
Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and Wisman.
Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke Lovai,
Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams, Dio
Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie Martinez,
Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Junior. Old
Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy, Zigoren,
Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel, Thomas
Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin Galbert,
Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman. George
Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler, Alexander
Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jannes
Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean Nelson,
Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks to
my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas Stink, Tom
Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull, Catherine
and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al Nick Cortiz,
and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers, Matthew
Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank you
for all.